[Music]  Your Majesty may I present to you the  greatest detective of all time Sherlock  Holmes and dr. John Watson  I love you oh look I write Sherlock  Holmes his methods are ingenious there  he's a master of disguise what have you  done with Sherlock why Watson I never  left and his mind is brilliant angle of  approach compensate for open floor  termination listed in buckingham palace  solve this case in four days or I will  kill the Queen science professor James  Moriarty wants it we have a killer to  catch up shall we begin the autopsy dr.  grace heart  the doctor impossible fortunately we  have a real doctor here would you like  some heroin  [Music]  I have two days left to live so this  case Majesty would you mind if we had a  picture together who's going to take the  photograph I will take it you see it's  sort of a self photograph he's a real  fan I swear I never do this  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]